Jimmy Diamond gave a speech if he can
pull that up Rob if you have it Jamie
Diamond gives a speech he's at a
conference I don't know where he's at
and they ask him about America he gives
the speech I retweeted this and I said
anybody that's willing to sell America
like this guys I wish there was more the
reason why I like seeing I respect
anybody who runs whatever country they
run they should be a nationalist of
their country being proud when Putin
sells uh Russia and his approval rating
is the highest in the world I think is
that 80 or something when he sells
Russia and we bash America and the
approval rating of ours is low well our
history we have a bad history we're this
we're that look at what Jamie Diamond
says here go for it the other way around
America has the best hand ever dealt of
any country on this planet today ever
okay and Americans don't fully
appreciate what I'm about to say we have
peaceful wonderful Neighbors in Canada
and Mexico
we've got the biggest military barriers
ever built called the Atlantic and the
Pacific
we have all the food water and energy we
will ever need
okay we have the best military on the
planet and we will for as long as we
have the best economy and if you're a
liberal listen closely to me in that one
okay because the Chinese would love to
have our economy we have the best
universities on the planet they're great
ones elsewhere but these are the best we
still educate uh you know most of most
of the kids who start businesses around
the world we have a rule of law which is
exceptional if you don't believe me and
we talk about Britain Brazil Russia and
the Venezuela Argentina uh China India
believe me it's not quite there we have
a magnificent work ethic we have
Innovation from the core of our bones
you can ask anyone in this room what can
you do to be more productive ask your
assistants Factory floors we do it it's
not just the Steve Jobs it's the broad
death we're the wise and deepest
financial markets the world's ever seen
okay and if you I just made a list of
these things and maybe I missed
something go it's extraordinary
it's extraordinary it is America yes we
have problems how easy it is by the way
do you know when this speech was from no
take a guess
I don't care if it's 10 years ago a
month ago or a day that's my point
that's great it's Timeless yeah that's
my point the speech was in 2016. America
think about where we've come
in the last eight years seven years
since this speech it says it's as
relevant and as poignant as ever and
he's being called upon by what Bill
Ackman these days left and right bro you
gotta run now's your chance not your
chance you know he's 67 years old worth
almost two billion dollars by the way
forget about the fact that he's 67 or
two billion dollars you know he's got a
900 million dollar art collection and a
secret building he's built but have you
seen this thing pull up Jamie diamonds
900 million dollars let me tell you more
about this guy do you know he was an
assistant a personal assistant to Sandy
wow you're not what company in 1982
American Express that's where this guy
got started as an assistant to Sandy wow
and more importantly today
do you know how much money every day
circulates would Chase 10 trillion
dollars a day in 170 countries in 120
different currencies that's this guy one
of his famous quotes he said
uh if you don't bring up the problem to
me it's your problem
if you bring up the problem to me it's
our problem trust me you want to bring
me the problem okay I'm prefacing what
he said but this but again yes the
Epstein stuff what happened in 2013 when
they stopped doing business with Epstein
and they said look we don't want you to
be here they cancel an account even
though he was with them for 30 years and
they said well we never communicated
with them there was like 1200 email
exchanges with one of the guys Staley
that was working there there is that
side of it but the point here is we need
more people in America to sell America
100 I don't give your military I don't
care if you're a capitalist I don't care
if you're a politician I don't care if
you're in a media space sell America we
have such a great argument to keep
selling America I'll give you the final
thoughts here before we wrap up well
this is going to be a very nerdy final
thought but I'm not sure if you're
familiar with the work of Charles Murray
uh the bell curve gets a bad rap but he
talks about how America is one of the
few countries where it's actually better
to be born smart than it is to be born
rich just because you have the idea of
self-determination it's one of the few
places where you can work hard and get
what you are worth which is not the case
for the vast majority of countries out
there and it's something that we take
for granted that was basically how he
ended his speech I know you got to run
odds he actually runs and what party he
would run give me five percent here's
his answer when they ask him if he's a
Republican or Democrat he said my heart
in my heart I'm a democrat in my brain
I'm a republican he's always kind of by
the way that's kind of like the script
on you to see over big bang for Goldman
Sachs you have to say that yeah but it's
less than five percent I think what is
going to happen is the sooner they get
rid of Biden the sooner people are going
to get in does he have a shot Jamie
can't speak he can sell his charismatic
he's he's talked to everybody he knows
Finance he knows politics he's been
around he's done the power plays the
guy's a genius the guy you know he's got
a philosophy that he follows called The
Fortress philosophy and you know what
his philosophy is have a ton of cash he
had a ton of cash when they bought it
it's a very good philosophy to have yeah
so I think five percent chance but it
has a lot to do with what happens here
soon the sooner they fire Biden the
sooner he can in it all depends on how
quickly they do that so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]